cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Donald Trump is actually a
moderate Republican that's why he's
winning November 19th 2015 and then on
November 25th 2015 Donald Trump is a
fascist now hold on the original article
Donald Trump is a moderate written by
Jamel Bowie and the second article
written by Jamel Bowie the same dude a
week later
he wrote Trump as a moderates wise
winning then he wrote Trump is a fascist
why they are evil there is no legitimate
reason why a sane person would say I'm
gonna write an article calling Trump a
moderate and then a week later be like
I'm gonna write it oh no oh I just
discovered is actually a fascist no what
happened was
everybody was going after Trump
so this person probably thought if I
write that as a moderate I bet I get a
ton of traffic from people who are going
to be like what what do you mean how how
and then a week later okay been there
done that I'm gonna write Drums of
fascists and get a million more views
welcome to the media yeah I think you're
right it's it's part of the click bait
they need you to be so shocked by the
things they're saying and these points
that they're putting out there uh I I
find the hysteria around Donald Trump to
be completely personality based I bet
most people can't really distinguish
anything about his political platforms
or I should clarify most people who are
identifying as Progressive journalists
they they don't know the nuances of
differences between Republicans they
just know that Trump does things they
don't like and they don't like him the
most and so therefore whatever they have
to say to make him the bad guy uh it is
weird there are times when you'll see
sort of more left-leaning Outlets almost
praise other Republicans to make Donald
Trump look bad when there's sort of no
informed opinion other than they aren't
Trump so therefore they're whatever
they're doing is okay but this type of
disinfo that calls us hysteria and panic
is so dangerous but I mean when you
ingrain into let's say 50 of the
population that that
um this Republican front runner is is a
fascist then that label then is applied
obviously to people who would vote for
him those who support for him and then
what what what what's your good moral
people do against fascists when we want
to bash them and it normalizes that type
of acceptance of political violence I'm
speaking unfortunately as somebody who's
been a victim of the violence of antifa
because of these labels that have been
applied to me and then I mean with my
the event that I just spoke at in
Richmond the script that was going out
to these different venues that that
canceled and took the third venue if you
meet out should be able to speak people
would just call in and say things like
you have a Neo-Nazi who's speaking there
are armed neo-nazis who are coming this
event goes forward people could actually
die and people in corporate PRS or just
freak out they're like okay well they'll
cancel it and that that's the danger I
think of you know we can laugh at this
and look back and because I think we're
always here at the stable or grounded
but there are actually so many people
even highly educated perhaps it's the
most educative who are vulnerable to
this type of Hysteria and this info but
I you know we I take it so seriously and
I
um I'm so angry at how
um
sloppily people use these labels of like
fascists and like dictator and all these
type of terms as as if it's like okay to
just throw it around apparently now you
know people just do that with like
Reckless abandon and it's like you you
know people who
um instill that into the beliefs like
actually take take up weapons and like
maim and like kill people and not belief
that happened in Portland with a a
self-described and two phone number who
shot dad a trump supporter because he
really thought this guy was this white
supremacist fashion it's just murdered
him in downtown yep so
you were saying before that you felt
like the younger Generations are sort of
fueled by this political divisiveness so
they won't listen to other people and it
it makes sense because they're
completely surrounded by it uh there's
no escape and there's no accuracy in
reporting
yeah that's true that's true
I I always I always wonder if there is
going to be a reckoning it with at what
point you know we have
we have maybe Margaret Taylor green on a
couple a year ago or so and uh someone
who's at the table said oh I'd actually
never listened to anything but Random
clips of you and hearing you talk it
definitely changed my opinion or it gave
me an Insight uh and I I find this
really interesting because I think there
are so many people who aren't exposed to
anyone but other people who are
similarly afraid of these labels of
fascists and you know anyone who's
brushed by the these words are obviously
out to get them and so there was a
natural
it almost makes sense resistance to it
you you don't want to be affiliated with
them but if the if you're completely
right if the labels are are misused then
their fear and their willingness to
maybe react violently is based on
inaccurate information during the Trump
years I would always try to reach out to
the other aisle just because it was like
uh it was it was a Hot Topic you know
and I would always hear from people wow
you're actually the first Trump
supporter I've talked to which is crazy
because how have you ignored half of the
country you you've just been so
tight-knit in your bubble that you
haven't even thought of you know what
let me check out the other side I used
to be a Democrat back in the day and
then when I was uh coming of voting age
I said to myself I'm gonna make an
informed decision I will check out both
the right and the left and I just found
that the right made more sense to me and
I wish more people would do that what
made you want to do that though because
I think it is unusual I think young
people tend to be like oh that's what my
how my family votes is how my friends
vote the thing that made me want to do
that was intro to logic I took that my
first year in college and I learned how
to critically think and this was also
around the time where BLM first wave was
popping off and I didn't like how they
kind of wanted to make black people the
victim so much so that was rubbing me
the wrong way and then I took intro to
logic and I said let me think
objectively rather than subjectively let
me go outside my bubble let me see
what's on both sides and then the right
made more sense for me yeah
I think people don't want to be outside
their bubble I think and and
conservatives are guilty of this too
that we shouldn't you know pretend
otherwise but some people just want to
be told the way they see the world is
completely correct they want to have all
their biases confirmed always but I
think that's what's really dividing the
the left and the right the culture war
is no longer politics I think it's
obvious to anybody's been watching a
show like this for a long time it is
simply are you someone who is an
independently minded person or are you
someone who is terrified of being
shunned Democrats basically just March
in lockstep with whatever acceptable
opinion is whatever popular thing
currently is and it changes and catches
people off guard and they get yelled at
and they apologize and they freak out
the reason why they'll get so
irrationally angry at the idea of you
defending Donald Trump is because they
know they know you're right
when when they when the media lies about
Donald Trump and then you say well you
know Trump never did that they'll start
yelling at you why are you defending him
why the reason they're getting angry is
because they're like uh oh I'm gonna get
ostracized I will get targeted if you
keep talking like this I've got a show
that I'm I'm against him I'm not one of
you yeah that kind of it's like they
realize what they've been doing for so
long and they realize they can turn
against them you know it's like when uh
was it was it David Hogg said he was
going to keep wearing masks even though
they got rid of the mandates because he
didn't want someone to think he was a
republican yeah they are so terrified of
being the out group so what happens is
it doesn't matter if your pro-life
pro-choice
it matters are you in the cult or not
you can be in the cult and you can be
someone like you know Adam kinsinger Liz
Cheney or Joe Walsh they are obvious
cult members It's the funniest thing to
see Democrats have a high approval
rating for George W bush so long as you
are part of the machine cult the
cathedral you know there you go do you
guys think people on the right uh
um
a bit too loose in in their accusations
of their political opponents of being
communists and socialists you don't no
why so there's uh as we've been talking
about this quite a bit over the past
couple weeks the banality of evil and
malicious evil or you know as I go even
further say abject evil so how did the
Nazis how are they able to pull off what
they pulled off where did we hear this I
think someone's talking about it here on
the show maybe that there was a group of
uh regular guys that were conscripted in
World War II and when they were they
became police officers and when they
were ordered to just start you know
gunning down and rounding up the Jewish
people for the concentration caps
without question they just did as they
were told Michael malice often says that
there is uh I I don't know I don't know
I can't say the exact quote I'll
paraphrase but something's the effect of
there is no crime so egregious that
police would not carry it out if ordered
to up in uh including up to and
including the murder of children I
certainly think that would be the that
would be the case if they were
instructed to do so as we saw in Lina
when uh we have all these missing
children and people are saying that they
were in the cars trapped and the police
were blocking the exit to Lahaina so
that people were trapped in the Road and
they were burning to death and then some
of these people jumped out of their cars
and jumped into the water while the cops
held the road closed because they don't
care now did those officers wake up and
decide that they were going to go murder
a bunch of people of course not
they were stupid people who did not care
for the responsibilities of their job
who were told don't let anyone leave
town not explicitly but they said shut
this road down and they went you got it
and so while the fires were burning
people to death they were cops like
don't care
so when it comes to the accusations of
the right
on the line on the right uh yeah from
from the right about the left then uh
that's what I meant by on the right
they're making these accusations
I don't think it's uh incorrect to say
that they're Communists did every single
communist in the Soviet Union who
supported the system or participate in
it know that they were Communists did
they read literature on Marx or they're
just doing as they were told
they were just doing they was they were
told it was the commonplace ignorance
that led to these evil actions so you
have high profile individuals like uh
people in the Fulton County DA's office
charging Donald Trump they're evil you
have the people in New York City that
are filing these lawsuits falsely
accusing Trump of things or trying to
charge him on these these these BS
charges you've got the documents case
against them all of this is complete
garbage nonsense you have the Democrats
who in 2016 claimed falsely that Russia
manipulated the election to help Donald
Trump win and Trump was illegitimate
then 2020 comes around and when when the
opponents of Biden start saying similar
things about fraud they say you're all
crazy Psychopaths Etc et cetera they are
a combination of all things evil
powerful interest at the top who say
things like can't we just drone this guy
in reference to Julian Assange in London
Hillary Clinton is evil but then you
have the blind ignorant followers so if
you have high profile activists who
raise hundreds of millions of dollars
who say that they are marxists
explicitly that's black lives matter and
then you have people Marching In the
Street throwing up the red salute in
support of overt communism they're
Communists yeah they don't have to sit
there and and put their hand on the on
the Bible of of of Mark's capital and
things like that they just need to be
cogs in the machine that actively
support them the issue of Communism and
then you have people breaking free from
that saying I don't want to be involved
and that's fine they can but for the
time being if BLM is coming out saying
they're trained marxists and then I see
videos of Millennials and gen Z doing
the red salute
oh brother Communists like if you saw a
17 year old kid marching around Goose
stepping and doing a Roman salute you'd
be like he's a Nazi oh wow hold on did
he actually read mineconf does he
actually come on dude wait we don't put
we don't play those games so the issue
now is high profile activists to the
tunes of millions of dollars buying
property having the slogans so
ubiquitous that Amazon and Walmart use
them like okay yeah they're they're
they're in the style of Chinese
communism they are authoritarian call
them whatever you want they adhere to a
to some kind of marxist ideology likely
as a means of manipulating I think it's
probably better to call them
neo-fascists or something like this a
lot of people call them neo-marxist but
I'm like I don't think they actually
believe what Marx believed they're using
Marxist ideas to manipulate stupid
people and into being controlled so it's
something else
neophishistic maybe whatever but call
them whatever you want to call them
Marxist Communists it applies to all of
them
yeah and you can and you can wake up one
day and be like oh that was bad that I
was doing that there's a guy who I
retweeted a while ago he was a doctor
and he tweeted that he was completely
wrong about the lockdowns and he
apologizes the data was bad and he
regrets where he was and I'm like see
there you go you know somebody who says
whoa I can't believe what I was doing
yeah and you can really do that in One
Direction you know if the left corner
the right you can't do it from the you
hear me from the left or you can read it
from the right going to the left I don't
think the left would just never have you
no they do they they have their their I
I think it's all fake the people were
like you know what I was a trump
supporter and then I realized they were
like no you didn't that's a lie that's
not true because the the far right as as
defined by the media and the
establishment includes Libertarians who
hate Donald Trump yeah so it's like
somebody who was you know I'm sure there
are people who have been blue pilled who
have been manipulated and tricked into
believing lies from the machine but you
have to be really insane or really
broken to read
facts about how the media lied which
brings you to Donald Trump and then be
like yeah but then I started reading
more of the of of NBC News and really
just decided not to fact check it
it's like that simple
I'll give you an example barisma is the
best example especially with
everything's going on
there's no circumstance in which you can
unlearn the barisma Scandal and if you
go and say I don't support Trump you
know Biden's the guy for me go into a
circle of Democrats and say oh yeah but
you know about Victor shoken right when
he signed the sworn affidavit saying
biting on him fired they're going to be
like you're a Nazi you're far right get
out yeah for who it was that you're
talking to bro you read that from the
show about that they had knew nothing
about it I can't remember who it was now
well that's Rihanna woo yeah that's
right that's right it was Hunter Avalon
they have no idea the stuff happened or
they're lying and saying they didn't
know that it happened but the reality is
the people who are like you know I was a
trump supporter and now I'm not okay
maybe you are a trump supporter because
you are living under a rock and your
neighbor said he was voting for Trump so
he said sure but you're certainly not
someone who pays attention
what's your take do you think that
people are inaccurate when they
criticize the left is being communists
um well if Tim is specifically talking
about the militant activists who use
those symbols that are associated with
Communism well clearly those those are
out
um labels for them I just you know I
cringe often when I just when I see
people on the right very kind of loosely
just calling random large sweat swaths
of the political opposition just you
know they're all these are all just all
Communists or we're using using the term
fascists as well it's just uh the one's
true and one's not language is so
important and meaning in the definitions
of words is important
um I just you know I think playing the
same game of what the left does of just
you know their disregard of how they who
they call fascists or who they call far
right whatever I think the right should
be very careful or not to mirror that in
the same way unfortunately maybe that I
think that's so that boat has already
sailed but why shouldn't they mirror it
are you implying that they're only
saying it because it was said of them
yes and it's it's about sort of like
just this rhetorical claim of like okay
you call us you know you're so loosest
word uh fascists on our side where we're
just gonna call all of you but that's
not what's happening it is a fact that
they're Communists it is not a fact some
of them but they but right so you're
defining communist as someone who is a
learned red communist as opposed to the
banality of Communism not even
necessarily learn it they could just I
mean somebody who's just finds appeal in
the basic tenets of Communism if a guy
is uh puts on a black hoodie and runs
around with antifa smashing they see a
communist
not necessarily he might identify as a
militant Anarchist that's a big part of
the antivirus but that's but that's not
Anarchy Anarchy meaning without
Authority right so they can call
themselves whatever they want I don't
care that's not true
anarchists are not violent
right
well if the far left there are examples
in in 20th century European history of
you know Anarchist ideologues have
carried out assassinations
and other types of violence so I would I
would argue the core of the of the
phrase without Authority
would displace a person from the use of
violence and someone who wants to claim
they're an anarchist who then engages in
say throwing dynamite in the market or
something like that they're not an
anarchist that's an authoritarian action
Anarchy is quite literally the word and
without arche Authority anybody who
believes that there is no authority of
the system one could make the
philosophical argument that they're
trying to strip Authority from the
system that's why they're an anarchist
that's not correct in most and most
Anarchist philosophy that's why you'll
find among Libertarians and what people
would refer to as right anarchists the
non-aggression principle if you use
violence against another person it's an
assertion of your authority over them
which defies itself what what is
actually happening is if you look at the
anarchist communities they have
inherently tanky authoritarian views on
how to run Society then they just say
but I'm an anarchist sure like dude just
because you're stupid doesn't mean
you're not a communist if they believe
Marxist ideology utilize that Al G2 and
utilize violence to that and they're not
anarchists they are someone who believes
in an authority believes in a system
believes that it should be done the way
they want it done and that they are the
ones who have the the right to use cause
of death to get that that's not Anarchy
so this is the issue that we've always
had going back to Occupy Wall Street
when these dudes would dress up in all
black and people would call them the
anarchists and stuff and we would
colloquy colloquial colloquially say it
sometimes but being friends with a bunch
of anarchists especially with like Ron
Paul Ron Paul Revolution only a few
years before we were like that's not
Anarchy running around smashing windows
and beating people up because they don't
agree with you is quite literally what
anarchists are opposed to when you when
you argue that the police for instance
were doing something wrong and they were
abusing people or saying the street was
frozen you couldn't go there it was an
arbitrary exercise of authority over
people that was ill-gotten it was it was
it was it was false
when people start putting on hoodies and
masks a uniform going around saying do
what we say or we will physically strike
you I was like identical to the police
and they would go that's so stupid we
are not I'm like bro two guys who are
part of groups that dress the same and
assert their Authority whether it's
warranted or not
but but this is just the the no true
Scotsman argument no it's not it's it's
the it's the if someone comes to you and
says they're a thing does it mean they
are a thing no it does not words Define
things so if someone comes to you and
they're clearly a white blonde guy and
they say actually I'm a black guy from
Nigeria you're gonna be like you're
actually a white guy right within
political philosophies if there if there
is a a faction that identifies within
this larger political ideology and they
carry out actions that
um in the name of this ideology I don't
think we should necessarily just say
well
they're not acting truly in in for this
particular cause I you know I I get into
there are a lot of
um women's rights activists who actually
really disagree with the work I do
because I I particularly talk about how
a lot of these women's rights events
it's antifa trantifa Communists and and
socialists and violent far left coming
up to attack these women who are
speaking out about trans ideology well a
lot of these women who are speaking out
are old school leftists who say no no no
these people they're not leftists
they're not on our side they have
nothing to do with us they're they're
regressive they they're not they're not
on the same side as us and I think that
type of denial
um
it's it it's not reflective of the
reality that the on the ground
manifestation of political philosophy
does change over time you're not going
to have necessarily a pure manifestation
every time but it's still part of that
and I think there you know I think
within the wider Anarchist Community you
anarchists need to start asking
themselves a bit more if they're not
doing already why are some of the most
prominent anarchists we see doing the
direct action on the street are the
militant anti-focus because they're not
anarchists
you like your position comes from the if
a person declares themselves to be they
are that I disagree if a communist came
out and said don't worry I'm not a
communist am I going to be like well
hold on guys they're not a communist
he's like he's he's wearing a a you know
a a blue jumpsuit with a little Kami hat
on holding Das Capitol and waving a
communist flag is I am not a communist I
say okay he's not
he said he's not so he's not right
that's that's illogical
well that's not what I'm saying and you
know you can have
people can pick and
um uh cherry pick whatever
aspects of different texts or historical
figures who may represent that political
ideology and draw inspiration from it
and say that that is you know that
they're part of a longer tradition it's
just
all right
and I I just get frustrated when there's
like uh so the so the issue right now is
not recognizing a problem on one own
side which I see the left does but the
right is a lot wrong to call them
Communists so Libertarians conservatives
evangelicals post-liberals
non-politically Affiliated people
comprise the far right all of those
people I just described this disparate
group of people who completely disagree
with each other and will actually yell
at each other in arguments are called
one group fascists all of them
that's nonsensical and incorrect you get
a Libertarian you get Dave Smith in here
and he will tell you why he does not
like Donald Trump
they will but the media and the
Democrats will still claim he's a trump
supporter thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time